here's the pin now for Miller right in
the right hand side his screen in the
middle of the floor they'll set a ball
screen oh that's a good point Miller
takes it strong Miller with the left off
the window tie ball game Miller guarded
by GG two of the most highly touted
freshmen of the country this year Miller
with three Miller to the rim Miller with
the left hand
[Applause]
Miller absolutely feeling it draws a lot
of attention pulls the trigger deep
breath hey Miller putting on a display
25 Miller surveys wants a ball screen
gets one from beniako
Miller
beautiful just gliding his way and that
is a new career high for Brandon Miller
37 points tonight
Florence elevated rolls around pass up
ahead to Brandon Miller
and Brandon Miller getting out in
transition look they're looking for this
young freshman anytime
one last crack got it Brandon Miller
at the Buzzard average over 82 a game in
League Play and they are well on their
way
wow
all stemmed from the past
challenged by Miller Alabama basketball
oh and a bad break there Hardwell was up
there but it was still on the rim
oh and in transition Miller with a
finish he was shooting 65 percent on
unguarded threes Miller takes it strong
and drops the hammer oh my goodness
[Applause]
wow
but to your point Texas a M's so good
Ravi they come into today top 35 in both
offense and defense they just ran into
watch it
explanation point
s exactly where I was going you can
start counting the number of possessions
left in this game there's not enough
right now for Arkansas can't create
something off their defense
Miller for three is Noah Gurley where's
your get back defense and through the
Aggies wasn't there and Miller buried at
three he's got 18 just like yesterday
makes some defensive plays in this game
[Applause]
and actually hit him in the elbow he was
up so high swinging over to the other
end is it gonna go yes